hello guys my name is Ryan right and I'm
Dan Schneider those dopes we're gonna
watch a couple of movie clips today for
a movie that some people have heard of
very small indie flick called guardians
of the galaxy super indeed super indie
flick we had a budget of like $100,000
it's something like that hundred small
small is really small but I've run the
trailers I've seen it looks like it
could be like a two hundred million
dollar picture it could it could it very
well could with this
Chris Pratt guy this Chris Pratt yeah
I'm never star yeah yeah everyone knows
you're Chris Pratt is I love Chris Pratt
so much I get like real progress awesome
[ __ ] he was great in lego movie oh
you [ __ ] awesome in that a five-year
engagement movie he's cool he's a
collector
Moneyball he's definitely earned his
spot yeah yeah definitely yeah like
Chris Brown like Chris pet paid him
$5,000 for this role $5,000 really yes
five thousand yeah yeah but you know he
doesn't for the art not for the money he
does it cuz marble marble does not pay
well ya never become like Robert Downey
jr. barely makes enough to live yeah
he's scraping by right now barely I mean
he's probably got what what yeah if even
yeah that let's watch this movie that's
automatically gonna make a [ __ ] ton of
money I cannot wait it looks like a ton
of fun alright first clip we're gonna
watch first clip we're gonna watch
called star-lord it's gonna be about
Pratt I love it oh my god
drop it uh hey I got getting hot drop it
now hey cool man no crime no problem at
all how do you know about this I don't
even know what that is I'm just a junker
man I'll just just check us out you
don't look like a junker you're way to
ravaging God
just the outfit man ninja turtle you
better stop poking me okay dude chill
all right woman may have push-ups for
you hey you know what there's another
name you might know me by star-lord -
who star-lord
yeah legendary outlaw guys no forgive
this whoa hotel so Chris Pratt's a
badass oh yeah he's a altra badass and
that we've seen in the trailers like
that little first section about like
star-lord yeah I I haven't seen the
action sequence afterwards that was
awesome no yeah who's just like one move
and then another that was really [ __ ]
cool man
he's like a cowboy song Pumped sweetie
do that got me really excited I was like
oh that's probably gonna be like the
beginning of the movie so oh yeah yeah
yeah to like see that that's like
alright I've got a good setup going here
it may be great get ready to introduce a
character alright now that's the other
one is called I have a plan it's all
part of the plan we have to stop Ronin
POW I have a plan you've got a plan yes
first of all your copy means when I said
I had a plan I'm not unique of a thing
to say
secondly I don't even believe you have a
plan I have part of a plan what
percentage of a plan do you have you
don't get to ask questions after the
nonsense you pulled on knowhere
I just saved quill we've already
established that you destroying the ship
that I'm on is not saving me what do we
are stuff like three seconds ago your
station
ah she's right you don't get an opinion
what percentage I don't know 12 percent
12 percent it's real ha ha ha ha real
authentic hysterical laugh of my entire
life because that is not a plant area
concept you're taking their side I am
Groot so what it's better than 11% with
that how does that have to do with
anything
thank you Groot thank you see hoots the
only one of you who has a clue
that movie's gonna be [ __ ] awesome so
good cuz it's like Marvel has yet to
have like us and insomnia cluding The
Avengers where it's like they have a
cast of colorful characters it's gonna
be funny - oh yeah please someone don't
say Fantastic Four Jesus it's not the
doesn't count I don't know what that is
a separate being it's like alright we
got like a bunch of really cool
characters it's gonna be a lot of humor
to and it's gonna add a section like
this is gonna be the summer movie I feel
it oh yeah ed like the chemistry between
all of them just like out of that small
scene yes I like how the clips are not
like hey let's show you much a crazy
action because you know Marvel's gonna
do good on that again there's good
they're saying like hey no we got
actually pretty good writing here and
good character and it's gonna be a lot
of fun because even these Marvel movies
are so serious now
except Avengers yeah yeah yeah yeah
lesbian trailers are right it doesn't
feel like this is another movie that's
supposed to be part of the Avengers
series like just feels like its own
standalone Marvel movie yeah so I'm
really excited for it really excited for
it I'm really interested to see because
they're gonna tie into the other yeah
but y'all just never had like it's gonna
tie in one way or another because that's
just how Joss Whedon is mmm so be really
interesting to see what they do and Joss
Whedon helps out with all them now I
hear ya he oversees like freaking every
agency Hoskins a genius he's great
brilliant and make look yeah I am in the
brief passion
to Joss Whedon Joss Whedon if you're
watching this I would make the hardest
love to you ever I would give you the
biggest hug for doing the greatest stuff
ever I'm talking penis and buckles okay
all right if you're new to the channel
oh so we're doing that kind of
transition it subscribe right here and
Dan has a gaming channel that's cyber
channel go into games you can check out
this link here pure fun and stop motions
so Ryan can I get a shout out your
videos are amazing your channels growing
fast I'm Ramon is that 13000 yeah we're
almost at 20,000 now he hasn't move you
might be at 20,000 down out this videos
up yeah I mean you two tanks for that
just in case
mm-hmm um yeah we're almost at 20,000
take two yeah we just passed 20,000 yeah
it's awesome
yeah that's growing it's growing it's
weird and the more subscribers you get
the bigger my penis gets it's funny you
bring that up and it's really bizarre
because before like they couldn't you
can tell because you know but now it's
just like it's the pants and I don't
want it I don't want to look at it so
actually if we could just stop it room
could just unsubscribe my penis is
getting way too big it's like abnormally
large it's like a mutant we had to bring
a Ottoman to sit it on you can talk now
has its own personality speaks it killed
someone wait what it took a gun it's
growing hands I'm telling you I can
barely breathe I'm starting to think
that maybe you just have a kid now yeah
that's what it is and again and his
name's dick yeah and he's a visa bastard
he's a real bastard she's [ __ ]
murderers people already poppy else but
the rejects time it's like hot dick come
on all right we talk anyway appear fun
um yeah I mean your title just may just
want to have some fun here just have a
little comedy banter for you hmm
so yeah except that banter as a gift to
you Gage Myers yay shut up please I'm a
big fan every time I watch your videos i
whip my
dick out smiley face righty the sweet
dude you know what
before I started changing the camera
angle my dick was always out too but I
can't show my dick on YouTube otherwise
you know although some people said on
the April Fool's prank video that they
get a lot of time of tiny glimpse of the
head of my penis if you've played in
slow motion so some fans have played it
in slow motion to see if you see the
head of my penis whether or not you want
to do that
I will not be it's a good head anyway
gauged um I hope I can gauge you more in
these conversations I hope that you are
always like wow I'm destined and I hope
your dad Mike Myers is doing great yeah
would it bring it home yeah not the
comedian um the the serial killer Oh
Michael Myers yeah yeah yeah I hope you
guys figure out what's a whole thing
must have created a really hard
relationship for you to have my dad as a
serial killer and who also dies and then
comes back on the dead I mean that's
just [ __ ] difficult to deal with
silly after the third time this is kind
of like dad just be dead please please
this is really confusing for me I don't
know if I want you alive so I have
grieved ten times ten it's ridiculous
let me good luck with that Aaron R Jones
hello give me a shout-out I will be so
proud well you should be proud my friend
cuz you have worked hard to get this
shout out you have watched several
videos and you have asked for one and
now you're getting one be proud we're
also sending gold stars your way yes
gold stars and golden glitter Jewish
girls you have those I have plenty I
have plenty they're all tied up in the
back of my trunk
oh yeah every time I come over here I
feel like I'm getting deeper and deeper
into some sort of legal activity that's
what she said